hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome attacking game that took place
in a qualifier qualifier on leeches for
the world Fisher random Championship
that will take place in Reykjavik and in
this bracket there were uh giri Meyer
Abdul satrov and abbasov and this is um
from the final game between Anish giri
and other satrov it's quite the game uh
you guys uh will enjoy it and for those
of you who are still not accustomed to
chess 960 once uh the uh the first few
moves are played it's pretty much a
normal chess game only the positions are
much more uh sharp so before we check
out the game we do have some news
regarding what's been happening in the
world chess.com I released a statement
so now I'm just gonna read it real
quickly they said dear chess Community
this weekend we are finalizing a
thorough investigation into the events
of the last few weeks we will share the
entirety of our findings with you next
week we know you are eager for answers
and it's important that we are
meticulous in our research and
conclusions we look forward to
discussing it with you in the coming
days uh signed the Danny wrench Chief
chess officer now they didn't say much
but they did say that we will or rather
should know a bit more in the in the
coming days now what I like here is that
uh dany's um title is is Chief chess
officer you know not just the chief
officer like a CEO but a cheese chest a
cheese uh Chief chess officer and uh you
know I just thought that when you know
when he goes out drinking to a pub or
something like that you know someone
asks him what do you do and he says like
I'm a chief chess officer uh people
would be like yeah I mean of course why
not that's that's a perfectly valid
title so I'm very glad they're using
Chief chess officer instead of just you
know chief officer but yeah let's get to
the game Anish has the white pieces and
he opens with Pawn to F4 and this is a
Blitz game five plus two so of course
players have to play very very fast with
D5
opening up his uh his Queen with Ponte
D3 and not Knight H to G6 we have pawned
the E4 on each strikes in the center
punta uh E5 now and pawn to F5 advancing
the pawn all the way uh chasing the
knights to a less active square and also
minimizing the activity of the black
queen so nice day seven we have Pawn to
G4 and each grabs even more space Here
and Now Pawn to A5 which is a very nice
move as it opens up uh some
possibilities for The Rook to join uh
the attack the the white thing is on B1
so some Rook A6 Rook the B6 could be
very nice so here we have Pawn to A4
Anish also has the same idea we have
Pawn to G5 and now Pawn to H4
uh just uh going after that pawn the
queen is also attacking it so Pawn to H6
we have characters captures and now
Knight H the G3 and now it's basically
only a matter of time who will claim the
H file for The Rook uh but abdusader of
first place D4 uh we have rooked the H1
by a niche and now Knight to C6 we have
Knight to D2 preparing to bring the
Knight to C4 and now Rook the A6 uh it
would be great if the Rook could come to
B6 but first Knight to C4 taking away
the B6 Square from Black's black rook
and now Pawn to F6 just closing the
position all the way Pawn to C3 now
Anish wants to bust open the position
and now Bishop to F7 putting pressure on
the Knight here and just Bishop the B3
now I will uh like I would like to show
you what uh could also be played here
instead of Bishop to B3 there is this a
very very interesting idea of Pawn to B4
I know again you guys like you're just
showing it because it's spawn to B4 no
it's it's a very very interesting
because
obviously you have a threat what if B5
happened so you have to react to this
and just capturing uh that doesn't
really do all that much so what could
happen is something like Bishop captures
and C4 the captors and C4 now a capture
Sun b4c captures on B4 and it seems like
you're doing uh wonderful here you're
threatening B5 but there is Knight
captures on B4 probably why Anisha
decided not to go for B4 it's it's very
hard to continue the game for from here
because of course if Bishop captures
then Rook B6 and of course the bishop
will be uh one back Bishop p7 is coming
and you will not be able to defend this
what you could do however is play C5 and
now uh the game just continues the
Knight can go back to C6 you go for a
queen to C4 very active Square for the
queen already attacking the rook and G8
so things are happening but of course
this is a Blitz game so players have to
move a fairly quickly Bishop to B3 was
played Queen to D7 uh adding a Defender
to the bishop and now Queen to C2 we
have Queen the E8 and now Knight to A3
now the Knight can come to 5 with
bishopter E7 and Knight the B5 a
beautiful Square for this Knight and
also once the C file opens up you might
have some very unpleasant pressure here
for black on the on the C7 Square so the
characters on C3 Big B captures in C3
and now Knight to D7 we have Rook to H7
uh forcing the trade of Bishops is now
uh Anish is threatening to pick up the
bishop on F7 and the bishop captures on
B3 we have Queen captures and now Knight
the C5 attacking the White Queen uh and
now Queen to C4 and now all of a sudden
anisha's position Comes Alive completely
he has some very very nasty threats here
if one of the Knight moves there are
some threats against the C7 Pawn also
there are ideas of maybe Rook captures
and an E7 if this Knight moves then you
can pick up the rook and G8 so you have
to be very very careful what you play
here abdusato plays Rook the h8 of
course he wants to trade trade the the
Rooks Rook captures Queen captures and
now we have Knight to H5 and this this
makes sense you don't want to allow up
the shutter of to get active with the
queen but it was better to go for for
this night right away it's a forcing
move and it's not easy for black to find
the response here for example if Queen
to f8 uh you can even Castle Queen side
this is something players maybe easily
forget of course not these guys as these
guys are very very strong Grand Masters
but it would be maybe a valid idea next
Rook H1 Rook to H7 uh very unpleasant
for black so okay night stage five by
Niche again this is a Blitz game we have
Queen to d8 and now as the D3 Pawn is
hanging you have to defend it King the
C2 a very nice use of the King by a
niche Knight the D7 remembering the
Knight to B6 to go after the queen and
here uh it seems like yes Bishop to F2
does make sense you wanna put pressure
on that B6 square but Queen to B3 would
be much better just waiting to see what
um what up the Saturn will come up with
after Bishop F2 there is a problem with
the position and Abdullah author of
takes advantage of it but the question
is can you also take advantage of it so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find a winning idea for another
back while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on uh realizing that
again it is about the B4 square and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is night the B4 with check and
now it looks like a silly move because
you're really not threatening anything
other than checking the white king the
problem is uh how do you react to this
if you if you move the king let's say
King to B2 all of a sudden Rook the C6
attacks the queen and there's no more uh
a way for you to defend the D3 Pawn once
the queen moves you're just gonna
capture on D3 with check and pick up the
three Bishop on F2 also one of the
reasons why the bishop uh did not belong
on F2 in this position it did in that
position where I said it was a better
move but not in this one so Anish does
uh the only thing he can he gives up the
queen for the Knight and Rook he plays C
captress on B4 and okay Rook the C6
Queen capture Sun C6 B captures on C6
and now Knight to A7 already threatening
to win the queen back with Knight
captures on C6 and end with a nice Royal
Fork here so King B7 another big defends
the C6 pawn pawn to B5 now Anish has to
bring all of his pieces into the attack
otherwise he will not be able to to
survive so C characters on B5 a capture
Sun B5 and now uh Bishop to C5 of course
uh another back wants to trade down as
many pieces surrounding the black king
you don't want to get checkmated or you
know uh for for for for some sort of a
night night check uh it's a Blitz game
and in Blitz and knights are very very
tricky bastards so Knights the C6
attacks the queen queen to f8 and not
Knight captures an A5 with check now the
a file opens up for the white Rook as
well King to B8 and now Bishop to E1 a
very sneaky move by Anish finding ways
to keep the bishop alive Bishop to B6
attacking the Knight and the bishop to
B4 now attacking The Black Queen Bishop
C5 and again Bishop to D2 Anish repeats
the position Bishop B6 with Bishop to B4
and again Bishop to C 5 but now Anish
wants to continue fighting Knight the C6
with check and of course if you go Keen
to see it then his game over Rook day to
check black resigns so here King the B7
only move for of the Saturn to continue
and now uh Rook the A7 with check
beautiful move by Anish of course now
the bishop cannot capture as a bishop
captures and if it would be in game over
so King the B6 and now the problem is
for example if the King was on C4
defending the B5 Pawn then just Bishop
F5 A5 is Checkmate and there's uh
nothing black can do here but you don't
have enough time to defend the B5 Pawn
so here we have Bishop to A5 with check
by Anish now comes King captures on B5
and now Rook captures um on C7 so that's
one way to one way to do it but it's
also very much winning for Abu satro now
uh we have Queen to A8 uh now putting
pressure on uh well just everything and
now Knight the G7 and each tries to
bring the Knight back into the game if
you go for a rook capture send these
seven dangerous Queen captures on C6 and
okay you do have Rook the C7 looks very
nice but it's really nothing Queen to D6
and now the bishop is hanging the bishop
cannot move because the Rook ends it
resides so here Knights the G7 uh if
Anish can get this Knight into the
attack as well then things will improve
for him drastically and the position is
now winning for Abu Saturn but he has to
find the very critical Bishop to D6
attacking the rook and now after Knight
the E6 preventing this because then
another Royal Fork check and picks up
the queen uh you you have to find some
like King day four you you get away from
all the forks and now uh the white
really has no moves if Rook the A7 looks
nice maybe you can do something but it's
a free night let's say this and then uh
if Bishop to C3 check you just move the
king and if Rook the A5 check there's
always King to B6 so there's always one
move missing um for Anish the you know
uh deliver this so after night the G7
Queen the h8 abdusato doesn't find this
he wants to go with Queen H2 check and
start harassing the white king but now
Anish is back in the game Knight to E6
and now there's another attacker now
there are two knights surrounding the
black king and a bishop and a rook so
Queen to H do check with King the B3 now
comes Queen to E2 going for the for the
D3 pawn and now Rook captures on D7
grabbing the Knight and also defending
the pawn on D3 Queen to D1 check King to
beat you Queen to e to check and now
Anish has to settle for a draw here with
a repetition of moves here Queenie one
king B2 Queen E2 check and so on uh
otherwise it's not going to be very good
for him but he plays King to C1 and now
it's just game over uh it's uh I mean it
was such an intense game that Abdullah
even missed a mating two here with
Bishop a A3 checking we won in Queen B2
Checkmate he went the other way with the
bishop Bishop to E3 check King to B1
Queen D1 with checking B2 and Bishop to
C1 check and it was only in this
position on move 48 that anishigiri
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here if you go to C3
it's just a very quick Checkmate Queen
D2 check Queen V3 and queen to B2
Checkmate as the king now covers uh here
all of the crucial squares and other
moves don't really help with King to C3
you're just gonna pick up all of the
material for example Queen D2 check uh
sorry uh not King the C3 of King to B1
or King day one if you go down the board
then a nice Discovery from the bishop or
rather the best moves the discovery from
the queen king B2 Queen C1 check you're
gonna play King the eight you know Queen
to C2 check trying to force the white
king into a dark square and now after
King to A1 you will play or even a king
day three is possible then just Bishop
C1 Checkmate but if King the A1 then a
nice Queen captures on C6 and that's
pretty much it Rook D5 check and we play
King the A4 and that's it Knights the d8
you can harass the queen but now just
Queen to C1 check King to Queen C2
checking A1 and now King A3 with
Checkmate to follow so very nicely done
Anish missed that Knight to B4 check
which was a very nice idea but as you've
seen he didn't just resign there uh he
found a very nice counter play with the
c captures and a queen sacrifice and
then threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries so also a lesson for all of
you that you know even if you if even if
you blunder a move like Knight to B4
check there always exists the
possibility of counter play and you need
to find it and continue fighting so here
Anisha of course found it and he was so
so incredibly close I mean it's such a
wonderful position if the B5 Pawn could
have been defended somehow uh that would
be that would be it but it couldn't and
he had to give it up to continue the
attack here he could also maybe just
play Bishop C3
and then continue fighting and sort of
survive let the King characters real
characters on C7 and the game is still
going but the black is is somewhat
better yeah so you know it it's a really
it's a Blitz game so it's pointless to
analyze deeply uh but I just do it uh
you know because the positions are so
nice you guys uh will enjoy it but yeah
of course it's a fight it's always a
fight and especially with so many
Knights on the board in a Blitz game uh
I mean this is uh the the Precision uh
with which they've played this is just
remarkable uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it
wins uh the bracket and he will be going
to Reykjavik to play the world Fisher
random Championship uh we'll see uh what
will happen as that will be a an event
that everyone is looking forward to uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and that little bit of info
at the beginning of the video I would
like to thank ravishing reptiles YouTube
James Doran lubook where is home and uh
so I love you I believe for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for uh watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up any
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and whatever else happens in the chest
world so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day